was it always like that field was it
always easy baseball was easy for you
were you
howard baseball wasn't easy did your dad
make you practice a lot would you have
one of those fathers that like just kind
of beat it in well you got to remember
now when i was growing up all we did was
play sports
we didn't have the things that kids said
we didn't have computers and iphones and
that kind of stuff were you pushed into
it or you just loved it right away
my father i was very lucky because my
father was an athlete
right and i was his bat boy for his
baseball water boy for his football and
ball boy for his basketball were you a
natural
no not at all you were not a natural a
lot of guys were
more ability than me but uh i had other
god-given talents i believe like
i had enthusiasm i still do i had a big
heart
i had worked where did they know when
did they know you like like
when mozart they did it because i was a
better football player in high school
when i was a baseball player then why
would
didn't you go into the football i don't
like school my mistake
and so instead of becoming a football
player you become a baseball player
because you didn't like school
because i didn't want to go to college
and play football the only reason i
wanted to go right into the minor
leagues and listen to this
the only reason i got an opportunity
because i had an uncle who was a scout
for the reds
did your father get to see you play yes
did he was he so proud of you yes he got
he got to see me play 63 through 70.
okay you got to see me playing the world
series you got to see me
uh when i had the collision home plate
in a 70 all-star game
i've never played hardball in my life i
was afraid the ball come to me and i'd
miss it
but you had none of those fears in other
words you were natural you were relaxed
right
that ball would come to you you didn't
panic am i correct
it's just like you don't panic with that
microphone in front of you
talking i'm fine oh you're great you're
the best coordination is a little off
well you know another thing i was always
very fortunate i always had great
teammates
well come on i did i had great i i was
surrounded by hall of famers
do you think it's ever going to happen
that you're in the hall of fame do you
think they'll ever forget well you just
i don't know i i don't you just have to
believe we live in america
and then americans are given second
chances but do you think there could be
a second trade do you think you could
get in
i would think i deserve one because i'm
the most positive guy there is in this
country about baseball
and you know baseball is easy to bash
today as you know